[Music]
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember so you don't have to it's time
to talk about the biggest letdown second
biggest one of the biggest a bad movie
man on the moon now you might be saying
to yourself what an odd movie to pick on
the 1999 biography on entertainer Andy
Kaufman may not have been a box office
smash but they got decent enough reviews
from critics and audiences praising the
life of the legendary comedian and the
performances that brought it to life
with game-changing talents lay Melo's
Foreman directing writer Scott Alexander
and Larry karaszewski penning the script
and one of my favorite childhood idols
Jim Carrey bringing a damn good
impression to the screen why does this
deserve such a bashing years later I'll
have you know Andy Kaufman's work you
probably saw this movie is okay if you
know Andy Kaufman's life you saw this as
a huge botched opportunity don't get me
wrong I'm aware biographical movies have
to take creative license when
translating a person's story to the big
screen ed wood is one of my favorite
movies despite many parts of it being
false Bohemian Rhapsody has a ton of
bullshit in it but I still thought it
was okay
even annabelle creation the spin off of
the spin off of the sequel of the true
story that's clearly 90% horse crap
I still have enjoyed so indulging in
cinematic elements that didn't happen
I'm actually okay with it's a movie you
gotta make an interesting story crammed
in a two-hour running time it's gotta be
some changes I suppose you want to talk
about my documentary where I act like a
raging - no Jim Carrey represented by my
bad impression I do not so why did you
act like such a douche oh that wasn't me
the fun-loving Jim Carrey everybody
adores know that was woke okra Carrie
welcome correct my enlightened to alter
ego that acts like he discovered the
meaning of life but is really using his
insecurities to judge people and act
like he's better than them he's over
there actually Critic you know you're
not really here but I am pull maybe to
your eyes but to my eyeball vision we
are nothing but ideas okay whatever
oh and don't ever use a gun again in
your reviews don't you use guns in a ton
of your movies well that's before I
became better than you or maybe I'm
playing a character right now I'm still
complex we call it Russell Brand's intro
believe it or not this actually has very
little to do with the documentary that
came out about the making of this movie
Jim and Andy where Jim Carrey Jared Leto
- everyone by pestering and even
sabotaging the movie set claiming he was
possessed by Andy Kaufman that's another
can of worms but it will come up briefly
later the big issue I have with the
movie is that elements of Andy's life
were made up when they simply didn't
need to be the actual life of Andy
Kaufman was really interesting strange
heartbreaking and even charming Kaufman
was arguably one of the first big troll
comedians playing with expectations
flip-flopping between making the crowd
laugh and annoying the hell out of them
but somehow he did it with a surreal yet
infuriating logic that somehow made
sense even if it was only to him well
there were big-budget groups that
dabbled in similar comedy this was
mostly what Kaufman focused on inspiring
many great comedians to create their own
style of anti humor so a movie about
this man should be both interesting and
funny so why in my opinion didn't miss
what the spirit of Kaufman was about
well let's take a closer look this is
man on the moon the film starts off
honestly pretty great
with Kerry doing Kaufman's for a man
character warning you that big chunks of
the movie had been made up for dramatic
effect I decided to cut out all the
baloney in fact he hated it so much they
cut it down in fact it's a lot shorter
in fact it's over he placed the theme to
lassie and the credits roll the theme
isn't even very long so he constantly
has to start it over as the credits stop
with it
this is friggin wonderful a routine
Kaufman himself when no doubt really
enjoy but then this happens he stops in
the middle of it we look at a black
screen of silence for about 12 seconds
and then Kaufman comes out in his normal
voice to say it was just a means to get
rid of the people who wouldn't
understand him actually the movie is
really great you know remember when I
said I'd go back to that Jim and Andy
documentary I can't help but think of
one line in particular Jim Carrey said
when he was Daniel Duchenne losing
everybody how far should I take this how
far would Andy take it
good question Jim well for starters Andy
won have stopped the credits halfway
through if anything he would make them
go longer he'd have that record
continued to skip and slow everything
down
maybe the record would scratch and break
and he has to get a backup and the
credits would start all over again but
he would play those credits all the way
through how far would Andy take it he
would have the universal logo shine at
the end along with the rating of the
film that used to pop up afterwards how
far would Andy take it he would tried to
head every theater that showed this
movie bring up the house lights some
would be confused and maybe even leave
and he would wait a good two minutes
minimum to give them time to exit or
leave others to talk about what the hell
was going on then then he would peek his
head out and the story would begin how
far would Andy take it that far
that's how far Andy would take it so
already from the very start there's kind
of an understanding of what Andy is
about but it's not being presented
don't get me wrong maybe this was an
idea and the studio said no saying they
could only do the credit bit for a
certain amount of time first of all
Jamie was so popular at the time
you know to get away acting like this
but he could have pulled some strings to
make this happen or as far as it could
plausibly go second it's unlikely they
ever planned to go all the way with this
bit because the rest of the movie has a
half-assed quality to it maybe it's
because they didn't know what they were
doing maybe it's because the studio got
in the way maybe it's because Jim got in
the way but it clearly rides throughout
the majority of the film take for
example starting off in his childhood we
see a young Andy performing skits alone
in his room which is totally true he
didn't play with many kids and liked to
pretend there was a camera in the walls
which concerned his parents he's told he
needs to play with other children so he
does the exact same thing just dragging
his little sister in played by Kaufman's
real granddaughter Britney
so anyone that's read and Andy Kaufman
biography knows what's next he gets past
his shyness by performing at kids
birthday parties he gets drafted by the
military but fails the psych evaluation
gets addicted to drugs and has a child
out of wedlock giving her up for
adoption and when he was at his most
lost addicted to drugs and loneliness he
completely turned his life around by
discovery
Transcendental Meditation balancing out
the darkest times of his life allowing
him to perform a kid's public access
show where he discovers doing the exact
same act for children before adults
instead can be surprisingly hilarious
giving him the inspiration to try comedy
which would be a huge defining point in
his life or he just goes to stand up yep
all of that skit and we just go straight
to him being a genius how much of that
would have translated so well into a
movie failing the military psych test
treating concern for him as a trouble to
he'll cast getting lost to drugs and
showing the struggle of him trying to
get his life together having a child and
giving her up showing maybe how he could
have longed for simpler innocent
realities and even the almost accidental
ways that longing for a simpler outlook
created his act and arguably who he is
the essence of where Kaufman's act and
Kaufman himself came from explored like
any decent biography would do nope just
genius now and nobody understands him I
don't know Andy I think I have to let
you go yeah seems a little ironic
because that's Kaufman's actual manager
George Shapiro playing the part of the
club owner in the film he's confusingly
played by Danny DeVito who was on taxi
with Kaufman again if this movie
actually utilized Kaufman's comedy they
would have made a joke about that
in fact Danny DeVito playing his
character in the show taxi doesn't seem
to be anywhere they just kind of act
like he doesn't exist why didn't they
make sure pure play Danny DeVito on taxi
and never address it in fact don't even
credit him just say Danny DeVito played
himself oh my god that would be
hilarious and it would totally keep in
Coffman's humor but nope DeVito just
plays the manager and they never
mentioned or show Danny as the character
on taxi how far would Andy take it he
totally avoided confusing and joke if he
could we see Shapiro witness Kaufman's
classic foreign man becoming Elvis
routine and he decides to become his
manager I've always wanted to play
Carnegie Hall
you're insane but you might also be
brilliant did you quickly notice this is
not going to be an honest portrayal of
the real struggles and
went through rather the forrest gump
simple beautiful genius who had
everything figured out we just had to
catch up to him I want to be the biggest
star in the world I want to generate my
my own material I don't want to go for
cheap laughs it's good old-fashioned
entertainment George is so proud
some of us at Saturday Night Live think
I'm the Kaufman's a comic genius it's
fun short they detest you we're a
success all the dialogue around him
works this way acting like he's the Mary
Poppins of comedy being five steps ahead
always in control and leaving us shaking
our head saying oh how when's it go
because I'm gonna do it again and again
and again look saying he's ahead of his
time is fine I'm a huge fan of his and I
thought he was ahead of his time but
treating him like a holier-than-thou
poet rebel martyr FOP just makes him
less relatable we can never be like him
or understand him because he was truly
perfect no he wasn't if this movie
showed any of his faults we not only see
that but it make him and this movie more
interesting but instead a lot of the
movie is just showing his routines
almost in their entirety even when it's
not needed and yeah I know the irony
that I said the opening should have gone
all the way with a bit and now I'm
saying they should have scaled back on
others but these are routines you can
see anywhere
many fans already know them inside out
and even non fans have a general idea of
what they were we're watching a Kaufman
movie so we can discover what we didn't
know about it not what we've already
seen a million times and you know what
if you're gonna do it show us the stuff
we can't see on the Dinah Shore show he
supposedly cracked eggs over her head
and they got into a fight sure hated
this so much that she had the footage
burned why not recreate that get it as
close as possible so people can not only
see how far he pushed it but also give
fans a chance to see how it most likely
went down when the movie does talk about
Kaufman's thoughts on his career they
get the basics down he did hate working
on a sitcom and would butt heads with
higher-ups about what he can do on his
own special but once again other things
are changed around for seemingly no
reason are you Andy Kaufman I get that
all the time Andy did work as a busboy
twice a week but
because he was trying to quit taxi it
was how he stayed creatively active
pretending to give him fights with
friends who acted like they didn't know
each other but they acted like they were
getting into this big brawl and
afterwards they would have a big laugh
about it it was keeping himself
creatively stimulated in a time where he
felt he couldn't do it on air which
would have been interesting to see him
cope by doing something unconventional
while he's forced to do something
conventional but here they act like he's
just doing it to protest ABC this isn't
nearly as fascinating as what actually
happened I also don't know how to take
him reading The Great Gatsby to a crowd
as punishment for them wanting to do his
character from taxi he would read the
entire book of The Great Gatsby as a
common form of entertainment even if the
crowd walked out it wasn't a means of
revenge he just thought it was funny if
anything even when a crowd was so bad to
nd he still did the show as planned
saying even though he hated the audience
he still should act professional as
possible and give them the show he
promised those people were so rude out
there and so anyway I went on and I did
what I was gonna do anyway and I went on
with the show and I did it for them and
I was professional about it but gosh I
felt like telling them they were rude
the stuff with Andy sleeping around and
the Tony Clifton outburst seemed to be
represented pretty well and it is nice
to see a recreation of him getting
kicked off taxi again something I feel
like the fans really wanted to see and
the movie did deliver on but again we
have to get a long drawn-out version of
one of his routines that a lot of people
seeing the film already know only this
time instead of not knowing whether Andy
believes what he's saying or not you
know he doesn't believe what he's saying
here when you see and eat want women to
wrestle he's portraying it as a person
who really believes what he says where
Carrie plays it like he knows he's
acting like a jerk which sucks out a
fair amount of the comedy now I'm not
saying women are mentally inferior to
men because when it comes to things like
cooking and cleaning washing the potato
scrubbing the carrots raising the babies
women are superior to men in many ways
cooking and cleaning in Washington
[Applause]
uh-huh but that wasn't me playing Andy
that was Andy playing me playing Andy
play me playing Andy playing a virtual
character who won deep I really like
original you better so does my box
office
[Applause]
[Music]
hey Doug Walker here letting you know
some of the conventions we have coming
up from June 7th to 9th is indy popcon
in indianapolis and you can get a
discount out tickets if you just use the
promo code awesome when purchasing them
from June 21st to the 23rd we have
Planet Punk in Iowa this is our first
time at this one insured to be a lot of
fun and from July 6 to 7th its Salt City
Comic Con at the New York State
Fairgrounds in Syracuse New York we have
even more conventions this year but
these are the ones coming up so go to
the sites get the tickets drop on by and
say hi would love to see you
[Applause]
so in the movies 25 minutes section
dedicated to Andy wrestling women and is
running with Jerry Lawler we do at least
get a little something the common person
didn't know Andy Kaufman's relationship
with his arguably most faithful
girlfriend Lin played by Courtney Love
who I'm not convinced isn't paralleling
Kaufman's life sometimes the scenes are
okay but again very short because again
a lot of the film has to be dedicated to
moments you can see anywhere else you
know it's interesting Andy kept sleeping
around even though he was in a serious
relationship with Lynn Lynn would even
go on record saying this was very
difficult to live with wouldn't that be
interesting cinema diving into a part of
Andy's life we didn't know the Oscar
that shit remember when Andy did that
remember when Andy did that of course
you do cuz you already saw it nobody
wants to see anything new in a biography
now some of you might be making the
argument that this is the point keeping
Andy's life a mystery so we never know
the full him well there's a right way to
do that too in the biography confessions
of a dangerous mind Chuck Barris his
book blended reality with fiction by
revealing some things that really
happened to him but then made up a whole
bunch of other shit like he was a
professional assassin the movie version
treats it like it all really happened
making it a very unique film in Fear and
Loathing in Las Vegas it's legally
fiction but most of its based on events
that really happened but the film still
shoots it like a drug trip where either
option fact or fiction could be
plausible in the movie Vincent all that
is is a great actor reading his diary
and showing the places that inspired him
to paint even though it didn't give many
details it somehow gave me more insight
into the person these are films that
tried something different and artistic
while confusing you what really happened
something Kaufman's humor was all about
a men on the moon done something like
that I totally would have respected it
just as much as a straight flora
biography helped maybe even more but
this is just blue teens he's already
done with occasional glimpses into his
life which half the time is made up
despite the real story being much more
interesting take this moment when SNL
asked their audience to vote if
wanna cost me to stay on or not
resulting in him getting voted off this
devastates Coffman because in the movie
people don't like him isn't that the
idea he does stuff so people don't like
him how does this make any sense it just
comes out of nowhere this is Saturday
Night Live the hippest audience of
television this is bad well the truth is
Kaufman was devastated but not for the
reason you think you see it wasn't Lorne
Michaels who made the announcement it
was producer Dick Ebersol Andy Kaufman
is not funny anymore agree with me why
does this matter because Eversole made a
deal with Kaufman they plan the vote
knowing full well that Andy would get
voted off much to his delight it's what
he wanted but then later Kaufman would
surprise people by returning to SNL
whether as a hero or a villain is unsure
but he was gonna come back to surprise
people in some way that's what the act
was gonna be Eversole however never
invited him back so not only did the TV
show that gave him a voice stab him in
the back but worse for Kaufman one of
his jokes would go unfinished and with
his OCD tendencies that even the movie
kind of taps on this must have driven
him nuts that's something we can see him
getting genuinely upset about but here
it's because people don't like it well
what did he care
the whole film they built up that he
loved that so this makes no sense so you
can't even get down the intent of his
comedy half the time know what to make
things dumber they have this stupid
reveals I don't think you two guys
should ever work together again I'm
sorry George
we just thought it was funny yeah you
see the way they edited that like they
hold on Danny DeVito for a while trying
to make it look like he's talking to
Andy and Bob zmuda but really it's Andy
and Jerry Lawler they're like oh my god
Lawler was in on it longer and andy
planned the whole thing it was a honk
it's wrestling if there's anything
people did need clarification on being a
Hulk it was this there's no part that
shows them planning it out or putting it
together they just want us to believe
that this was all really going on I
guess like whoa that was all planned
sure shocked me oh Jesus Christ I would
have to say all these nasty things about
women just to get them to come on stage
and just to define for the audience that
the audience should be booing me here's
another completely botched moment Andy
is kicked out of his transcendental
meditation group which seems to really
put him in a bad funk I'm a bad person
now as an audience member watching this
you'd probably be wondering why is this
such a big deal I mean you do see him
meditate once or twice he clearly takes
it seriously but again he usually
doesn't care what people think so why is
he wrapped up in bed staring at the
ceiling over this well again if they
treated this like an actual bio flake
you wouldn't know that he saw meditation
as the reason he was still alive he said
it saved him from the world of drugs and
insecurity and brought his life meaning
and purpose so yeah he probably would be
bummed out being kicked from that but
absolutely none of that is represented
here whatever big emotional response
they could have gotten out of this is
completely lost
he doesn't even except for very long Lin
enters the room and he quickly asked if
she wants to move in with him cutter
moving in with him sad meditation stuff
over so yeah it fails us being both a
small deal and a big deal somehow how do
you even accomplish that but perhaps the
biggest missed opportunity is when Andy
Kaufman gets lung cancer they skip the
scene of him finding out from the doctor
which I guess is supposed to confuse us
further and as you'd expect his own
friends and family don't believe him
plans these things he takes over and
hires actors you know personally I think
that doctor guy was very convincing I
mean these scenes are done okay and they
do move his big Carnegie Hall
performance to 1983 as opposed to 1979
long before he was diagnosed with
anything believe it or not I'm actually
okay with this sure didn't happen in
this order but it's kind of like having
the Queen Live Aid concert after Freddie
Mercury was diagnosed with AIDS it adds
an extra poetic weight to it it makes
the scene better which is expected for a
bio flick they change around a few
things in the show which again is fine
as they're trying to condense it
but here's where they dropped the ball
on an amazing scene they could have had
as a real-life Andy took the entire
audience out for milk and cookies in the
movie it stops there but in reality the
people weren't leaving and Andy needed
to tell them playtime's over it's time
to go home he shouted up people laughed
and applauded and went home the next
morning his writer Bob zmuda woke him up
wondering if he was gonna go and he said
the crowd knew it was a joke and nobody
would be there but then he thought about
the one or two fans that might have
confused what he said for real and show
up there all alone so he got dressed
went to the Staten Island Ferry and sure
enough there were over 300 people there
Andy was speechless for the first time
ever the audience had pulled one over on
him people kind of figured out he didn't
really have anything planned but they
didn't care if anything it made it
better the crowd fooled him for once he
bought the people ice cream cone sung a
few songs even did a little wrestling
but this was the first time he was
fooled by an entire crowd
not because of spite but because of love
love for his comedy love for his work
and love for him how epic would that
have been in a movie it's pretty much
the highlight of the entire flick you
can make it even bigger than 3-hundred
why not make it the entire crowd that
showed up you've lied about other things
why not lie about this to make the
moment even grander and bigger this
could have been the big tear-jerking
scene but instead we have a different
way he was fooled which also sadly did
happen Andy was convinced that a healer
scam artist could take the cancer out of
him but discovers it's bogus again it's
not a bad scene and I kind of like him
laughing as in this version he discovers
it while he's there but then it just
jumps to him being dead
this dissolve is so weirdly empty
honestly truth be told a lot of the
edits in this movie are they don't flow
in a natural wave they seem to more stop
a scene rather than end it it often
looks like it's interrupting a moment in
the middle rather than organically
transitioning to the next part of the
story didn't even have doctor shoes no
no no no he's definitely not dying but
seriously for the grant touchy-feely
tone this movie is trying to go for this
Denton Island Ferry Sea would have been
such a high mark to go out on you know
what's Bruin since you're switching a
bunch of other stuff around why did you
switch those two around maybe have
Kaufman go get the false treatment
earlier in his sickness like while he
still has hair and everything he finds
out he's been fooled in an awful way but
then he goes home to do the show where
he finds he's been fooled in a loving
way imagine you just saw that scene with
everyone sharing his arrival to Stan
Island he's so touched to see all the
people there cheering him they finally
fooled him it's come full circle and
then you dissolve to him in the casket
how much more powerful with that have
been what an incredible contrast of both
sadness and joy however we get the edit
we got and the film ends with Tony
Clifton returning one year later singing
I Will Survive never revealing who
actually played him and okay ending to
what could have been an emotional
powerhouse of a movie but you have two
minutes what Andy would have wanted
I know I was him for five seconds just
now you know that's another reason I
brought up your soul possessing
performance if you really cared about
representing Andy Kaufman correctly why
don't you focus on making his story more
interesting rather than making your
story more interesting well I'm just an
actor I don't have that kind of taller
you stop production several times on
this flick I'm sure you could have
pulled some strengths and said hey maybe
we can make this more faithful are you
saying I made this movie bad no actually
your acting is pretty decent in this oh
good as long as I could attention but
like a lot of people who made this movie
or even saw this movie the focus seems
to be in the wrong
a man on the moon doesn't help you
understand an artist or his art any
better if anything it makes you
understand it less because they change
so much of how he performed his art and
the reasons why like I said before I
wouldn't mind too much if it made for a
better story but Kaufman story was
already interesting and the changes made
surprisingly make it boring it's like
they felt they had to put changes in
because that's what bio pigs do despite
the changes not being all that needed in
this case I guess in hindsight it's not
an awful film the acting is still good
and there's a few times they start to
capture Kaufman spirit but it never
comes close to going all the way with it
and Kaufman was all about going all the
way with a routine no matter how much
trouble it got him in if you like the
film more power to you if it got you to
look up more about Andy Kaufman fair
enough like I said before I don't really
hate this film as a standalone flick I
hate it because of what it could have
been what it should have been it's not
one of the worst films ever made not by
a longshot but it is one of the biggest
letdowns which should have been one of
the easiest stories to make are grabbing
retouching fascinatingly weird or both
turns out an underwhelming best of
compilation that's not even that great a
best of compilation you know maybe I
have been trying a little too hard to be
deep indeed if there's anything Andy
Kaufman has taught us or this movie for
that matter it's that the best art comes
when you're being honest to yourself no
matter how weird you are what do you say
we go back to our roots and just try to
bring people joy I would like that
[Applause]
I can see this turning out just follow
my god mmm I'm the Nostalgia Critic and
I'm afraid we're all gonna remember that
they're going to do a redesign yeah hey
Doug Walker here hope for the Warriors
is this week's charity shout out hope
for the warriors provides comprehensive
support programs for servicemembers
veterans and military families they're
focused on transition health and
wellness peer engagement and connections
to community resources they believe
those touched by military service can
succeed at home by restoring their sense
of self family and hope their core
values understand the challenges pride
and joy of being a military family they
strive to meet the changing needs of
those who served and the families who
showed support right alongside them
because hope for the warriors believes
in family united by the shared
conviction of honor and sacrifice if you
look at their site you can see all the
good they accomplished and all the brave
men and women who have given up so much
so that we can live the lives that we
live if you want to show your thanks
click on the link and share how much you
appreciate all that they have given us
[Music]
you